I actually believe everybody knows what
their passion is I believe they talk
themselves out of it because they think
it's silly or it won't make money you
know you love music cooking the
Transformers sailing I think you know
that I just don't think you think you
can make a profession out of it yet I
believe if you went ham and made content
YouTube videos a podcast I know for a
fact you could make a hundred thousand
dollars a year through brand deals
selling hoodies speaking but people are
scared of other people's judgment when I
was 20 most of my friends number one
passion was video games nobody not even
myself thought video games was a
profession back then if one of my
friends had the conviction heed the call
that I'm saying out loud today they
would be a Pioneer in the video game
industry making six figures doing the
thing they love more instead of being a
retailer executive or a lawyer some of
you need to take the risk to start
building content around the thing you
love the most and that content may lead
to your ability to monetize it which
will then change the course of your life